[Music]
I can help you mathilde rgo her
desires to coordinate
health safety comes to check the site
was not aware it's a
surprise check like all checks 2 the
fps to see the site manager  please
yes of course I'm going to get
someone rosalia you can come please
day hugo de sps material for
this search for conductive caps
to be perfect then the check is
going like this check of the
sanitary facilities check of the kit
first aid and the first
aid certificate of one of the workers present
on the site
then I go to the control of
the safety equipment of the workers
is it ended up by controlling all the
guardrails okay and it is an element
not  was not in order I would have
to interrupt the work
you can go get the
first aid certificates and the neubourg case kit
or please of course we
start with the sanitary facilities
it is there
you know who has  the keys to the
offices yanis or rose elsewhere not the
keys to the office
well yes they went to carry club where you
mean the keys to the office are in
the locked offices it's a
problem
listening to ionis call because the one who
had locked the  dock offices I
want to move on but
at some point I will have to
access the first aid kit
otherwise I really have to see what
work can stop them the champions
will still see late penalties
and that is not possible there is no
will in the agglo he took down the sps
me
here broke down the door
I progress to make us swallow everything and
therefore I was able to let go of his foot to
do like doing everything  say
[Music]
an attack
now really how he can't
wait for me to finish my case is
really disappointed with his race yes
[Music] please do
n't mind
so
[Music]
and
last mutated or the key of the guru it  is
fast I'm only a little coffee it
makes us happy
no really I wasn't going to make a
negative report even though I don't have
access to a determining element of
security it's good I scraped very well
c  it's over here
so I'm daddy this ocean
[Applause]
[Music] [
Music] [Music] [Music] [
Applause]
[Music]
oh